[Music]
Bree Havasu Coubertin Eva mostly Nico
can say sarcastic - no no - no it's cozy
Toma Toma you know de algunas Ocho de
política same insulted our etiquette
America I recruited a new gonna tell
Claire couturier honey mahoto 7ko
sundial Atari toca - energy No
so no Monica kite a good
[Music]
it what a survivor a asthma Maputo this
hangouts got a human no cars no more
yep Thomas Mohan is your name Omaha
national negative momentum Ottoman model
doc look look commander at the day the
manga Caucasia the very night to go do
their tomatoes on our way to sake the
Miss Kitty yes optical return 139 of
akagi's was a guy I Mattoon an
out-of-office big project to me mother
technical another sensational getting
Joe Kusum on masters my mom my Witcher
cool community hana will get our
daughter or not to more motive Okinawa
so car has not there the conquer sorry
all budgets again society today
[Music]
Kurama university so diversity project
they were a star downtown an arena
downtown no one on each Bobby McConnell
can't a lettuce Busan s him boom Cara
saying we have angry know what are you
doing yoga
listen it's awesome a music you know
monomania up on the scribble scratch
even gonna talk I'll stick feeding the
last day actually give me all kinds some
money to another target an autonomous
car associate aggregator economics
[Music]
the Kurama economy and Yokohama Tony
charity good day Marie Marone Maharaj
decided that hey hermano optics
the Centrino process is just really open
automatically
so as O'Day a schematic could not
technically nominative this I go a
Boogedy style a coup de Muro sinhala
America ha ha ha Camilla's a there
Tejano secretes could be so jagged
[Music]
tell them home to Luhan and the zoo
dedicated on a more level aa home times
how valkyrian me go look I need to kill
a dog no it's tokenizer
that was good she can take a second on
their decide to meet is tomorrow night
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
no solo negatives Kohana what's kappa
gauges in all 19 are not more so
emotions are the market
[Music]
cool man dr. Cordova as I see ni hana
woohoo again ago today
Mahalo naught RC bo similar to Luka AB
realistic me to meet a good deal man
come on take it
[Music]
there's a lot to love about living in a
big bright city people culture
late-night food but there's something
missing it's there but you can't see it
the night sky this is the story about a
small town in Colorado actually two
small towns in Colorado that are devoted
to space West cliff has a population of
564 residents and silver cliff has a
population of 575 this used to be a
mining community and then it evolved
into a railroad community and then into
a ranching community we're always
looking to do something that will bring
people into our community and lately
that seems to be we need to invest in
our sky so they made like pollution
their enemy they darken their towns so
that the night sky could become their
star attraction have you ever seen the
Milky Way that goes from Horizon to
Horizon 88% of the world's population
has never seen the Milky Way it's the
most magnificent thing in the world
that's what we see here but for the
town's to go dark they needed to cover
all of their lights not just street
lamps but the lights outside every house
and ranch near town that wasn't easy
this is a frontier town and I can tell
you frontier people don't like being
told what to do we had to win their
hearts and minds it took 10 years they
passed ordinances raise money to cover
the street lights and even build an
observatory
and the darker the town became the more
people saw the light this year
the valleys dark sky was designated as
one of the darkest in the world drawing
visitors from all over that a community
would decide to dim its lights and help
everyone to appreciate the beauty of the
night sky is an amazing thing you come
to a place like this and the stars just
burst and it's remarkable not a lot of
people are lucky enough to see the dark
sky as our ancestors saw it and I feel
that we're a very special place to be
able to look at the Stars
as people did thousands of years ago
it's a humbling thing suddenly you
realize you can almost touch it and
you're now a part of the bigger universe
and so it's just a wonderful experience
to see the dark skies and that's what
we're trying to preserve
[Music]
[Music]
listen this sound is the first evidence
of the Big Bang and this is a story of
two radio astronomers who discovered
proof of the beginning of everything
this is the horn reflector antenna at
Bell Laboratories Robert you tell us
what this thing does it receives radio
waves coming from the direction that's
pointed to and funnels them into a
receiver that's Robert Wilson radio
astronomer in the early 60s he and his
colleague Arno Penzias were tasked with
measuring the brightness of the sky
using the horn reflector antenna but no
matter where they pointed it the antenna
read a much larger signal than the pair
expected our immediate reaction was that
there must be something wrong with our
system they thought it might be
interference from the horn itself or New
York City or even some pigeons living in
the horn you know we thought about a
collection of ordinary sources that are
in the very distance that just didn't
seem to be possible so they reached out
to a group of researchers at Princeton
University led by astrophysicist Robert
Dickey who had been scouring the sky
unsuccessfully for evidence of the Big
Bang Arno called and Dicky picked up the
phone and they started hearing things
like atmospheric radiation sky
brightness all the things that they were
working on Dickie put the phone down and
said boys we've been scooped Robert and
Arno had measured what Dickie and his
team are searching for the elusive
cosmic microwave background radiation he
thought about a Big Bang source of the
universe realized that it would be very
hot and therefore a full of radiation
and as the universe expanded that
radiation would simply cooled and
whereas it was extremely hot to start
with by now it would simply be
microwaves now it's so cold that it
would just be radio waves and this nut
pigeons of the noisy City was exactly
what have been causing headaches for
Robert Wilson and Arno Penzias the two
groups of researchers from Bell Labs and
Princeton each wrote complimentary
research papers with their findings they
wrote one about the theory we wrote one
about our measurement and we published
them I think unlike many changes that
occur in science
there really was a paradigm shift with
very little pushback it was huge
there was no evidence of a new theory
for the beginning of the entire universe
of ridicul a berber wilson Arno Penzias
were awarded the 1978 Nobel Prize in
Physics how that feel Robert felt pretty
strange to win a Nobel Prize I didn't
feel comfortable being on the same lift
with Einstein but despite Roberts
humility there's no doubt the
significance of the discovery it gives
us our earliest picture of the universe
from which we can extrapolate back to
very early times there's one of the
centerpieces of cosmology
[Music]
[Music]
my name's Tim Doucet I'm an amateur
astronomer and I'm also legally blind
kind of an oxymoron isn't it it turns
out I can actually see the night sky
better than most people probably better
than you when I was younger it's it's
easy to become discouraged you know
realizing that you're never gonna drive
a car that you'll never be an astronaut
at least that's what you're told
I was born with congenital cataracts
they remove the lenses of my eyes and
widen my pupils that left me with only
about 10% of my eyesight for the average
person their pupil automatically adjusts
for the amount of light coming in it
opens the closes but for me my pupil is
open so it's always letting in a lot of
light during the day I see everything
extremely bright everything is
overexposed colors are more vivid
but at nighttime the tables are turned
and it's like a curtains been lifted
[Music]
when I was a teenager I went on some
additional surgery to improve my
eyesight I got home from the hospital
and I looked up at the sky and at first
I thought I was actually having a
detached retina I was seeing millions of
spots of light and realized that that
was the Milky Way I was looking at and
it was phenomenal
[Music]
at first I didn't really realize what it
had given me
I took 15 years later to realize that
what I had was special with my personal
savings I built an observatory on a hill
near my house and called it deep sky I
when I'm looking through a telescope I'm
not wearing my glasses and my eye is
like a camera without a lens so it's
focusing the light very clearly onto my
retina I see a little bit extra light
that most people would see
you know you look at the Orion Nebula
and you know it looks like a fuzzy patch
but you know I kind of get a little bit
of purplish tinge to it the sky here is
like a tapestry of interstellar dust it
looks like a velvet background you know
with diamonds all through it it's
absolutely amazing
my wife is also legally blind
she doesn't see very well at night but
most of the time when we're you know
walking to her at the observatory I'll
explain to my wife what I'm seeing she
appreciates the night sky even though
she doesn't see it very well when I look
through the telescope or look up at the
night sky makes you realized really that
all your problems with fact that you're
legally blind or or whatever it really
just doesn't matter you realize that
you're a part of this universe
[Music]
[Music]